The Param Vir Chakra (roughly, the “Wheel
of the Ultimate Brave”) is India’s highest
military decoration for gallantry during battle
and is “awarded for rarest of the rare gallantry
which is beyond the call of duty and which
in normal life is considered impossible to
do”.
The medal is known for having one of the most
stringent selection process of any military
award in the world and 14 of the 24 total
recipients were killed during the action that
earned it.
One such posthumous recipient was Yogendra
Singh Yadav…
The problem was that Yadav was very much alive
and heard about his own heroic death while
recovering in the hospital.
Born in 1980 in the village of Aurangabad
Ahir, Yadav was the son of former soldier
who’d fought in the Indo-Pakistan wars as
part of the Kumaon Regiment.
Yadav, along with his brothers, would frequently
spend evenings listening to their father’s
war stories and tales of famous Indian military
heroes.
This instilled a deep sense of patriotism
and duty in Yadav from a young age, so it
was no surprise to his family when he decided
to join the military at just 16 years old,
joining the Grenadier Regiment.
Yadav subsequently proved to be a formidable
asset to the military, quickly rising through
the ranks and eventually coming to serve with
an elite commando unit of the 18 Grenadiers
called the Ghatak’s- basically, elite shock
troops tasked with being the first boots on
the ground in any conflict.
On May 3, 1999, Kashmiri and Pakistani militants
managed to storm and take control of several
strategic forts and bunkers along the border
that had been left abandoned since the end
of the war.
This action prompted the start of what became
known as the Kargil Conflict- a series of
bloody confrontations between the two countries
that lasted just over 3 months.
One of the most strategically valuable points
captured was a group of fortified hardpoints
atop a 17,411 foot (5,307 m) tall mountain
known colloquially as “Tiger Hill”, or
officially as Point 4660.
As the tallest peak in the Kargil region,
Tiger Hill allowed the enemy soldiers to look
down on the 56 Brigade’s headquarters, as
well as watch the Srinagar-Leh highway for
troop and supply movements.
Unsurprisingly, the top Indian military brass
demanded its immediate recapture at any cost-
enter Yadav’s commando platoon, the 18 Grenadiers.
The mission of the 18 Grenadiers (which has
been called one of the most brazen ever attempted
in open combat) was to scale an icy, 1000
foot near vertical section of the mountain
and assault the 3 fortified bunkers atop it,
while artillery bombardments distracted the
combined Pakistani Kashmiri forces stationed
in them.
Yadav (who was just 19 years old at this point)
wasted no time volunteering to climb the snow-covered
peak unassisted and lead the assault.
Yadav’s mission was to affix ropes to specific
areas so that the rest of the near couple
dozen 18 Grenadiers squad could follow him
more quickly.
Trained in both mountaineering and alpine
warfare, Yadav was an exceptional climber
and was reportedly able to scale half that
section of the mountain in mere minutes- a
feat that becomes all the more impressive
when you realise this assault began at night
(roughly 11pm local time) and the elevation
in that area is approximately 17,000 feet
(5,100 meters), meaning light and oxygen levels
wouldn’t exactly have been ideal for such
fast climbing.
Unfortunately for Yadav, as he was closing
on the top of the mountain, with his platoon
now following closely behind, he was spotted
and the enemy opened fire with machine-guns
and rocket launchers.
The initial volley killed Yadav’s commanding
officer along with a few others of his squad,
all of whom were either killed outright or
who fell to their deaths.
Clinging both metaphorically and quite literally
to life, Yadav sustained three significant
injuries while pushing himself to climb the
rest of the way, taking two bullets to the
shoulder and one to his groin in the process.
Despite the injuries and being under heavy
fire with little cover, he managed to make
it to the first bunker, hurling a grenade
into it and killing everyone inside, silencing
the enemy fire from that position, allowing
his squad to continue their ascent.
Unfortunately for Yadav, the attention of
the second enemy position was now directly
on him and they opened fire on the young man,
who was soon joined by two of his companions.
Yadav then led this trio of death in charging
into the storm of bullets and rockets being
aimed at them, with Yadav ultimately managing
to reach the enemy bunker.
In the ensuing hand-to-hand melee in which
he used his climbing ice axe as his primary
weapon, he killed the four Pakistani soldiers
manning the position.
At this point, the surviving members of the
18 Grenadiers reached Yadav and were greeted
to the sight of an extremely bloodied and
injured young man surrounded by dead enemy
soldiers.
Remarkably, during his two headlong charges,
Yadav had sustained a further 12 bullet wounds
two “hand grenade wounds” and had his
arm broken and nearly ripped from its socket
by an explosion, leaving it hanging limply
at his side.
Yadav shrugged off these injuries (presumably
metaphorically as literally shrugging would
have been a tough act given the two bullet
wounds to his shoulder) and used his belt
to make a sling for his arm.
Next, he pulled out his pistol and charged
the third and final position.
Rallied by Yadav’s bravery once again in
the face of heavy, near point-blank fire,
the rest of his squad followed and captured
the final point.
News of Yadav’s valor and total disregard
for his own safety in the face of overwhelming
opposition soon reached the military brass
and he was immediately recommended for the
prestigious Param Vir Chakra at the tender
age of just 19 years old.
Now, the Param Vir Chakra has one of the most
robust selection process of any medal for
heroism in the world, which is a particular
point of pride for the Indian military.
The medal isn’t just awarded for “everyday”
gallantry- it is awarded for the “Most conspicuous
bravery or some daring or pre-eminent act
of valour or self-sacrifice, in the presence
of the enemy, whether on land, at sea, or
in the air”.
As such, those eligible for the award are
scrutinised at length by no less than six
different facets of the Indian military hierarchy.
To quote:
Recommendation for any gallantry award for
a soldier is initiated by the commanding officer
of a battalion to the brigade headquarters.
From the brigade headquarters it is passed
on after scrutiny to the divisional headquarters
and from there to the corps headquarters.
From the corps, after detailed discussion
and correlation of the claims, it is the send
to the command headquarters, where from it
is forwarded to the army headquarters in New
Delhi.
At the army headquarters it is finally scrutinised
by the Honours and Awards committee headed
by the army chief, which has principal staff
officers such as military secretary and adjutant
general as its members.
The decision of this committee is forwarded
to the ministry of defence for its final approval.
Needless to say, it was a curious, and embarrassing
thing, that they subsequently awarded Yadav
the Param Vir Chakra posthumously, despite
the fact that he was lying in a hospital bed
at the time.
Yes, not only had he sustained a body’s
full of serious injuries, but he made it back
down the mountain and to the base hospital.
In fact, after the award announcement went
out, it was Yadav’s young wife who subsequently
notified the military brass at the base hospital
that her husband was indeed alive and reasonably
well all things considered.
It is often claimed that the number of serious
injuries Yadav sustained combined with his
unbelievable actions were such that it was
simply assumed he’d died before making it
back to medical aid.
However, the selection process for that award
is far too rigorous to let such a thing slip
normally.
What actually happened is that in Yadav’s
squad there was another soldier with the exact
same name- Yogendra Singh Yadav – who did
die during the battle.
As a result, when the living Yadav was recommended
for the Param Vir Chakra, officials attributed
the remarkable actions of Yadav to that guy
instead- whether because they simply assumed
the Yadav who died must be the one who sustained
all those injures and performed the unbelievable
acts, or simply because nobody noticed there
were two Yogendra Singh Yadav’s on the squad,
isn’t clear.
To further confuse things, it’s also noteworthy
that the other Yadav was among the first to
scale the cliff after the surviving Yadav,
and that both men engaged the enemy in ferocious
hand-to-hand combat.
During an interview from his hospital bed,
Yadav was asked to comment on rumors he was
planning on taking an exam to become an officer.
Yadav responded that he would like to, but
had to pass his high-school exams first…
Once again, he was
just 19 years old.